hey buzzfeed i'm whitney and i'm mallory
and we start in the movie stop and go
today we're going to be playing never
have i ever quarantined edition
[Music]
oh
what is too much really though let's get
to the bottom of this do you only buy
them for like one roll at a time no they
come in rolls of like eight
hey no
no the honest truth is that i did not
buy any toilet paper what you got get
more private girl no first of all bidet
i have a bidet oh yeah second i have a
roommate she bought the toilet paper and
she was quite reasonable about it
i peed on myself
[Music]
i feel good for people who like to put
their suit on
but like i have zero shame about like
attending
any any meeting in my full pjs top and
bottom as soon as that face and hair as
soon as that bbc reporter had his kid
coming in and then his wife following
after their kid i think the whole world
took the cue that we're at a new
standard of living
[Music]
i don't think i have no i have not
winnie's married so i mean and we did
not date and overzoom they weren't we
didn't go on any zoom dates while we
were quarantined together does it count
if i've had one with my mom
oh
[Music]
i haven't
i don't think your apps can't oh well
then every day for the past 10 years but
if they don't come then no
[Music]
yeah i got into plants over 20 20.
i was never a plant person before then
and then i saw one at trader joe's
because trader joe's was my happy place
during the pandemic
[Music]
have you seen our movie you've seen all
my faces no erin uh just let us grab
nana we're already on our way
[Music]
what is happening
[Music]
oh
yeah that's all i bought it is so great
did you know stars above from target has
a new line of joggers i feel like
beyonce made it okay to wear comfy
and be cute
[Music]
yeah i did it with feel good on netflix
like immediately when the pandemic
happened i think one of the first times
that i binge watched a show in one
sitting was before we even had streaming
services and it was with you it was
alias oh yeah we watched the dvds we had
all the dvds and we watched i think
three seasons yeah in 18 hours i've been
binging since 2002
so
thanks so much buzzfeed now you know a
little too much about it
make sure to watch stop and go in
theaters